thank you to both rocket money and hellofresh
for sponsoring this video more on them after
the reaction [Music] people citizens of the reject
Nation it's me Tara Erikson and this is I Greg ala
introducing me I forgot yeah yeah yeah anyway
that's that guy listen you guys voted whether
we were going to watch Percy Jackson or Lucy and
you guys voted on this Percy Jackson that's what
we're watching today y we love you guys also
don't forget to leave a like a comment ring the
bell ring the bell ring the bell well you know
what's weird I I'm surprised people voted for
this because book readers really didn't like this
movie oh really I know nothing about the movie or
the book I know I'm like who is Percy and why
is his last name Jackson I'm on the exact same
page as you I have no clue about any of the
story I haven't even seen the trailer for The
the Disney Plus show so I'm like I don't know why
people like this movie or don't like it but we're
going to judge it just off the movie and I'm
going to judge him for having two first names
first and Jackson get out okay now listen thanks
to pre for helping us edit down these videos guys
if you haven't been to the real reject Nation
Shop nope it's reject naations shop.com get
a t-shirt show them the T-shirt Greg just do
it come on now thanks dear get it in there do
the thing also we call you super sexy if you
join patreon super sexy is like cool you can
sing it with your own coffee well it's a whole
like PR Jack with me and cooker GRE and John
offer exclusive highlights and watch alongs
over there on patreon so get on get with it
if you know what's good for you should we get
started we should get started okay let's do
[Music] it you know I met the person
who plays Percy Jackson Logan lurman
you did nice gentle man did you tell him
hey I've never watched anything you've
done yeah I didn't watch your biggest
movie oh Chris Columbus he did pixels
oh oh The Lightning Thief that
looks awesome I want to be in
a stormm it doesn't storm out here
in La yeah what a [Laughter] [Music]
bummer whoa who aquam
man those are some fascinating
visual effects Aqua monster oh
is he like faidon is that the oh yeah the
water the water guy like little mermaid's
dad oh oh my God he's blending in with normal
society cool and all I had to do was let a little
water go he did the first Harry Potter movie
this director oh Chris Columbus right yeah Zeus
Zeus oh Sean Bean wait is that a a racist term CH
Bean totally got his name wrong my God we got to
mute that now besided it's been many years what
do you see thunderclouds but no lightning who's
that stolen you think I took it omnipotence has
blinded you brother those American flags fake we
are forbidden from stealing each other's Powers
but our children aren't I haven't seen him since
he was a baby he doesn't know me or even know who
he is because of you Lightning Thief yeah okay I
want to steal lightning he must return the Bol
to me in 14 days by midnight night on the summer
solstice 14 days is a decent amount of time so
the son it must be Percy Jackson or there will
be war [Music] w I don't know if he needs the
lightning I mean he just blew right through a
concrete door it looks like guys are destroying
New York landmarks for your own scuffles wa and
and and they answered my question about destroying
places and the Olympians the Lightning Thief okay
so it's play on I love him that's that's Logan
lurman I just when people say names I nod and I go
aha but you have to show me a picture he must be
the son yeah who stole the [Music] lightning this
actually an amazing shot is he really underwater
I'm like are you holding your breath for that long
yeah is he really underwat good job buddy no he'd
be dead by now right I wonder if they like slowed
it down or if it's just a visual attack shot
maybe he really knows how oh that was dope was
that a hidden cut that must have been that was
cool first SE Jackson as a beast how long was
that 7 Minutes 7 minutes that's nothing how do you
do it I just like being water this one place I can
think oh he doesn't realize he's like the son
of a God that he's son of Poseidon I'm Miss DDS
your substitute English teacher would someone
please explain what Shakespeare was trying to
convey in this line from aelo let me go to chat
gbt and I'll tell you [Music] well uh what is oh
he's dislexic he's chat gbt oh he's dyslexic I'm
sorry I don't know I thought he was deciphering
oh my God I think he's just dyslexic hey Mom how
was school today Catherine Kaner I like her she's
an elf dyslexia thing is getting worse oh why do
you think that cuz he can't read maybe it's the
ADHD you know I thought this school was supposed
to make things better Percy I know how hard this
is for you so he's half human hi Gabe where's
my beer oh I recognize that voice it's in the
fridge it's supposed to magically float from the
ice box and into my hand oh I would knock him out
oh come on man you have to do that right here show
some respect right that's my mom right there yeah
dude Yo Joe pelana a smack him around would you
he's been good to us Percy in ways you just you
don't understand you're right I don't understand I
don't get oh my God I hope by the end of the movie
we realize that he's not really that abusive of
a guy that he's taken on a responsibility to care
for we just don't know Prodigy boy yeah but how
can he take care of them if he can't hold down a
job G because my first thought was he gives them
money he doesn't cuz he doesn't have a job Greek
and Roman galleries oh this is going to connect
to Percy Jackson's backstory and Poseidon is it
Poseidon I don't know if it's Poseidon everything
is about to change pery everything is about to
change dad I love that cliche of the bus
in front of the ghost they vanish with it
I always imagine the character just running
three of the brothers Zeus posidon it is
Poseidon they attain Power by over Pier broen
cronis chopping him into little pieces the three
guards have been Rivals ever since that teacher's
got her eye on him on several occasions they would
come down to earth and um hook up they would
hook up with Mortals nice he's one of them
half God half human oh can anyone tell me what
they were called oh I know the word other than
Supernatural uh oh my God I forgot it
Waterman no and a god a human and a God
that God exactly no oh what I was thinking of a
totally different word I'll give you a hint you
have something in common he is a chosen one oh
pus Percy percus direct it's not dyslexia it's
a gift so dyslexia people can just read Greek
all over the place that's the implication yeah
first yes we need to talk okay she knows I don't
think she's just a regular substitute teacher
okay she's from the water too huh oh she's
some type of Olympian so did I do something
wrong oh oh she like a bird I heard Wings
where is it oh w w how did you get up there
oh my God what is happening this is so
unexpected you stole the lightning bolt
I don't know you're talking about give
it to me give it to me oh Jesus oh my
God release him oh my God he's
something too I swear I'll tear you to
pieces so like everyone's got their eye on
Percy did that really just happened a fury
concealed in our school I should have known
who who does his friend know he must know
because he was at the pool with him and was
like hey that's why you're yeah 7 Minute Man he's
no longer secure here okay where should be moving
oh [__] A take this to defend yourself it's a
powerful weapon only use it in times of severe
distress the hell is that it's a pen this is a
pen take him to his mother and don't let him out
of your sight okay maybe it's filled with vodka
so his whole life he's been surrounded by people
just watching over him you would think all that
noise in there would have caused more people to
be like what's going on where did our teacher
go Sally more beer I got this guy look we got
to talk can't you see she's servicing me in my
friends don't talk about my mom like that you
baldheaded freak what Cal down oh hell yeah hell
yeah hell yeah where are you taking me what is
this camp for really special people am I crazy
or something Percy this is about your father
decided we got it right that time cuz we
knew your father was unlike any guy I'd
ever seen he was just dazzling he was
massive when he came out of the water
we were really in love Percy and then
you came along and then it it was just
perfect perfect Percy he looks like Zach
afron from certain shots he does leaving
you it was probably the most difficult thing
he ever did so we assigned a bunch of people
to watch over here oh so Zeus is a bad guy uh
yeah did you see that monster yeah Sor watch
out whoa they just killed a cow go are
you right is it me or is it raining cows
we're not even 20 minutes in this movie
Cuts past all [Laughter] [__] you we
got a bunch of Lord against my job W
who who what I'm half goat that's why
he walks like that am I not supposed to
be enjoying this movie because I really
am how does he get changed for PE
he's got HBS what fascin they had
they had to do the reveal at night
to to mask it in the visual effect
wa that's some pretty good effects though that
looks awesome pretty good effect that's very
sad about the car though here well this is
a fun set and fancy oh see Half Blood Half
Blood Prince ooh oh what are you doing this
is as far as I can go you're human she's not
allowed I'm not leaving without you you
have to you're meant to oh Bye Mom holy
[__] kill her kill her before his us what
can I do use the pen what use B's pen and
click it he's like a video game helper
character wo cool oh okay I think she's
gone oh my God he knows how to front
[Laughter] roll you got this Percy are you
okay oh oh wow he did it by accident behind
you
whoa
day one on the job Percy Jackson be taking
to that monsters Beast nice where am I what
is this place the infirmary been unconscious
for 3 days three days what do you remember a
monster my mom was there well you were there too
but you were some weird hybrid man goat thing
whoa that's hot all of it was real my mom's gone
I try man I really do frankly I'm just a junior
protector I don't have my horns yet you think
by the end of the movie he's going to get his
horns he will I certainly hope so he'll move from
Junior to senior protector and then he'll go kill
his stepdad this is Camp Half Half meaning what
I think you know half meaning half mortal half gu
oh guys watch the arrows newcomer oh so he's
just a regular amongst them they're all half
Bloods remember Mr Bruner said Sometimes they
come down to earth and they fall in love with
Mortals and then they have kids he was giving
that Exposition exactly at the right time you're
a demig God two points to Percy Jackson y those
effects are not bad they're very good you mean
his legs yeah yeah it's a place where you learn to
harness your powers you'll train to become leaders
Warriors and heroes this looks like professional
laring or just gymnastics when you try to read the
words Flo off the page right that's because your
brain's hardwired for ancient Greek not English
that called it that's what's happening with us
that's that's what happen that's why we're can
read that's why we can't read your impulsive Percy
those are your natural battle reflexes man they
kept you alive in your fight what does this movie
say about mental health your blood is special it's
the blood of a God we have the blood of gods
Terra demig Gods we are which is why were also
mentally ill this movie gives hope to everyone
diagnosed with ADHD and dyslexia and dyslexia
yeah love interest you can tell
by the way the frame rate changes
I think it's really just that
she's a hot red head what's her
name Annabeth daughter of Athena the goddess
of wisdom nice oh that's Alexandra didario
look at her this movie's old yeah they look
so young okay you were like 40 when it came
out yeah the mcira Centaur what are those
things the Centaur wait a minute is that Mr
Bruner oh my God he's a centaur I like how they
disguise themselves as people with disabilities
yeah I'm known as Chiron like did he hide all
that in a wheelchair barely he's tucked it in
I apologize for hiding My True Form but I
needed to keep an eye on you I hope you'll
forgive me you see him out of breath man
he hasn't been a he was just running around
the lake I like that attention to detail though
like got to be huffing and puffing a little bit
man go over there oh my goodness there diety
if they're played by adults go over there you
guys got a lot of catching up to do their
mother's the goddess of love so you know
where that leads [Laughter] welcome home your
father built this for you this little Shack
I think they just film this in Canada seems he
got some weight through it giant fork just like
little mermaid's dad head a tried it my father's
beside god of the seas why didn't anybody tell me
it was for your own s safety it's exceedingly
rare for a child to be born to one of the big
three who am I threatening Poseidon's Brothers
Zeus and Hades that's why your mother married
your stepfather okay his pungent odor masked the
smell of your blood oh my God that's hilarious cuz
of his oh my God there's other he smells like
[__] voice they could have got about it it's
hilarious you could have just doused yourself
and gasoline Zeus's bolt is the most powerful
weapon ever created and if it's not returned by
the summer solers in 10 days there will be a war
this is your problem all right not mine this
is about your world not mine this is about all
worlds homeboy adjusted to this world really
well yeah and fairly quickly what can we do I
want to take you to Olympus convince Seuss of
your innocence will that work someone's using
you to start a war what are we doing here let's
go now first we must train now other than being a
centaur what is there like a power a centaur has
they're magical but like the are like powerful
warriors I don't know anything about Centaur
other than they're half humans half horses you
know Centaur effects aren't too bad on Pierce
broen actually do you think there was another
guy back there with their legs yeah probably
in a green I got to play Pierce broen's ass on
IMDb This is py Jackson and he's going to
need a team we'll take them I'm Luke I know
this guy son of Hermes and Camp leader where's
your helmet no one gave me one Kiren you still
got your wheelchair kids going to need it this
feels like a very expensive Disney Channel movie
yeah anybody got an extra helmet please pass
it up oh my gosh she she's giv him the look
welcome to the blue soldiers my friend everyone
in position for capture the flag first team to
capture the enemy's Banner wins steady steady
now wa what a shot that's fun it's like Capture
the Flag but with swords and stuff yeah I always
do appreciate the feeling of actual costumes and
real extras wa that that's a cool shot first I
know where the flag's at come on keep your eyes
open don't get killed so train with actual swords
what if someone actually got killed or sliced
oh oh my goodness I'm coming buddy I'm coming
sons of Ares Watch Out w that's a sword that's
a sword it's ADR or something else oh
you guys take Camp way too seriously go
how is Percy Jackson keeping up oh she just like
naturally good with the sword go look for the
flag how did I just do that I don't know it's
in your blood Half Blood this script requires
you to survive what are you doing why are you
not capturing the flag we do need to get to a
point where Percy earns stuff though instead of
yeah instead of just being working for him yeah
just be lucking out all the time maybe this is the
point where he learns a lesson he's going to fight
the girl oh and she's going to kick his butt who
whoa whoa did you really think it would be that
easy no this movie is not predictable at all my
mother is goddess of wisdom and battle strategy
she's like Wonder Woman I always win okay I always
lose maybe we're both wrong do you always lose
dang girl okay heck yeah he was flirting with
you man he really liked you and now you cut his
face okay KY should we get in there and stop him
she's killing him man you got to
be kidding this is the best part
why o dude he is getting his ass handed to
I've been waiting for this to happen learn your
lesson
I like how they made her looking away and she had
let hot girl turn around yeah yeah one day hot
girl turn around you'll achieve it one day Tera
yeah hot girl turn around then they'll go no we
need somebody else rise get to the water heal by
the water go swimming it's in your blood will give
you power the element of Life H2O oh it's like
healing I bet for him yeah that's what I've been
trying to say over your I mean I heard you but I
was like oh is it just going to happen that quick
it is okay yeah Percy Jackson you're unstoppable
man jum jump in come on just go for a little swim
swim as long as he's always by the water he'll be
all right just carry a little
canteen with him he'll be fine
I've got a question what if he like
cut his hand and then he washed it
in the [Laughter] sink then it would
[Music] heal wow this dude is a Mary
Sue will you go out with me I
guess I don't always lose [Music]
they're a match made in Love and War oh nice cool
I give her a kiss out just make out in front of
everyone guys oh my God she looks turned on
she wants him I mean why wouldn't you want
him so bad right now dating the lottery
I don't want the lottery more [Applause]
how quickly that went does make me feel like it's
like a Disney TV movie but it's just cuz he didn't
go through much yet but maybe he will I don't care
I'm having too much fun with this movie oh it's
great it's really fun the movie is awesome that
did just happen quick though it's completely like
it's really cheesy but it's really fun it's really
fun Hey Percy um we're having party at our place
later and we would really love it if you came oh
ladies ladies please I would love to come too to
the party thanks for inviting me ladies Beat It
N oh Pierce them with his Jackson you know what
I'm saying you know what I'm saying oh I know
what you're saying I get a sense that you don't
like me very much it's possible I mean our parents
hate each other her dad's Zeus I definitely have
strong feelings for you I just haven't decided if
they're positive or negative yet I hope they lean
positive well you let me know and you figure
it out they'll be the first and Hell Jackson
you up this is amazing that Reflection
from the glasses was awesome I love them
together oh sweet that looks
cool scary oh my gosh that's
so big that is a demon entity Percy Jackson show
yourself oh my gosh show yourself
buddy Percy stop flirting get in
there stay back all right let's see what
the Centaur can do Percy Jackson bring me
the bolt he doesn't know what the bolt is yet
right he doesn't have the bolt he doesn't no
he's Bol in him and I will exch change
it for your mother oh prick my mother's
gone your mother is still alive I said the
minur to abduct her I like this design this
guy's got to brush his teeth yes he does
a the mom's just suffering Mercy what have
you done with my mother that's an odd line
delivery but I'm okay with [Music] it no say
be BR then did not look comfortable no he's like
he's like the oh man get
your watch get there would
you when he finds out you don't have the bolt
We'll Kill You Andel my life this is her only
chance why they have to shoot Pierce BR so
closely poor Pierce once you convince him
of your innocence we will do everything in our
power to bring back this movie has paced just
fast enough for me to keep up with what's going
on and to ignore the flaws yeah I love it it's
my kind of movie no no I'm going alone no I'm
coming with you no you're being followed I a my
black friend and my hot girlfriend let's go one
small victory and you're ready to fight Hades oh
double te really you two uh oh God my mother
is still alive I'm going to get her back from
the underworld look man I can't let you do this
okay I'm not asking for your permission God damn
it Ron and Hermione you better get your [__]
together if you're going to hang out Harry this
is something I have to do on my own yeah well
we weren't asking for your permission today you
tried to kill me now you want to defend me it
wasn't real that was just training really all
that slashing I've grown up here I've only been in
the outside world a couple of times and I've never
had the chance to go on an actual Quest until
now you've won one battle and I've won hundreds
you're going to need my experience yeah but he
like he whooped every he whooped everyone's ass
yeah but it's not cuz he earned it it's just cuz
he is a son of the top three gods and maybe she
her dad is top three I don't know who knows how
to get to the underworld I think I know someone
who might Luke hey handsome mhm welcome to the
modern world cool does he have a toilet why do
we need to know that Gregory the modern world he
has nature your dad is the messenger of the Gods
one of the only ones who's gotten in and out of
the underworld ah my dad's a jerk I've never met
him that's because all gods are the same selfish
they only care about themselves hey don't talk
about me like that but I once broke into my dad's
house got some cool stuff show us the toilet he
goes poop in nature in the tree that's like right
there I know I would never want to hang out with
them he pees and poops in that tree right behind
that sheet next to the centaurs then he burns
it w cool now I've seen everything has hundreds
of these little guys won't even miss them look
underneath the other one yeah but they're cool cuz
they're convert yeah so they're like modern and
hip stylish people have gone to the underworld
before without having to be dead Hercules did
it orus did it my dad does it all the time getting
in is the easy part getting out that's tricky look
how like cool and modern day every one of these
kids are they're like adults but they're not this
is a map to pran's pearls you mean hades's wife
yeah he forced her to marry him needless to say
she hates it there he's a weirdo so she has um
secret visitors oh Hades wife be having some fun
these pearls they provide a quick escape from the
underworld so how do the pearls work you take a
pearl you step on it you crush it visualize where
you want to be taken H now there's three pearls in
the United States this map will guide you there
right here is your first location McGuffin let's
go antm's Garden in Emporium New Jersey the map
will show you the next one and the next one and
then you're off to Hades oh my God scavenger hunt
you guys might need some extra protection a dis
this guy's got everything my favorite Shield
you might want to take a step back why is he
so nice I don't trust him I feel like he's got to
some he's like been so nice since the top I don't
trust him I don't trust him he's too nce feel
like he's leading the lightning Bol awayce I
know I think he's a plant this place definitely
needs an Extreme Makeover what if you just gave
him like specific jeans to wear then he wouldn't
need to like have the crutches right right but
then he'd have to have big yeah right right
well okay that's nasty for oh maybe it's cuz
he walks he walks where when he's a goat so he
has to that's like a it's the throw off descent
right okay sure it's Justified I feel like he
can formulate some type of he like walks weird
so then those those just he does when he's a goat
I swear he could just have like he could say he's
got like some type of condition that's what they
all do gold drmas that means we're on the right
track how are we going to find the Pearl in this
place sing it to you check everything good idea
I'm going to go this way I'm going go this way
I don't know why that made me laugh they're like
it's so small and you're like I'm going to go
this way what a convoluted adventure oh that's
lit Soph we stopped the direction my poor husband
help help me please help me this a trap don't fall
for the bait too late hey it looks like the Satan
guy no those are the horns he wants to achieve I
think he's just like my uncle fan yeah oh yeah
got the moan the same place I like the horror
Vibes Uncle F was killed by pe it it togethera oh
the counter in Medusa don't don't look at Medusa
oh they're all stoned please we have to leave
before she finds us she turn my husband is
Stone do you know Medusa no no well you will
they turns people to Stone listen where are
we we're in Medusa's layer a b we're lost we'll
never it's like a Cinematic Universe movie oh my
God what modern day touches it's so hardening
to to have such young visitors let's see your
hair oh yeah she has a hair of snakes now I'm
with it daughter of Athena how do you know me
you have such beautiful hair oh it is pretty
nice and thick and yeah very distinct I guess
I once had hair like that desired by many sutors
but that all changed because of your mother the
woman who cursed me she's got like the black
leather Matrix thing going on who turned me
love it into a snake Snakehead lady cool ew and
their mouths open and stuff I hope you find my
eye oh it's Uma Thurman duh I didn't you recognize
her right away yes that's why I went oh her how
can you not I had no idea that was my God Gregory
he doesn't know what is he even doing here you
know why why why are you
doing it oh can she hypnotize
them oh that's cool wait why did the lady look
lady can Medusa also hypnotize she said some
weird thing the lady opened her eyes why we
supposed to fight something we can't look
at we can look at a reflection check this out
all right good idea smart you make a wonderful
addition to my collection oh no no I love it this
this feels like a a teenager wrote it but I like
it it say this like Spirit of a teenager writing
it don't look annabet don't open your eyes who's
that another Dam God e oh the the close-ups
on it are are gross were they protrude out
of her skull or really gross I mean it looks
super freaking fake but that's not age well
overall son of posidon I used to date your daddy
oh oh dude oh all these you're crushing
all your friends Medusa sure come on let's
go I there's I guess there's no process
reversing the back also he broke the arm
part and she just took her hand out of the
hand uh just a quick note that didn't make
sense so she could have just taken it
off she could have just all you have to
do she does have a weird hypnotizing
thing cuz he's almost going to do
it wa wao watch out for the overkill all
right feel like if you just keep a blade close
enough to you you could just stab her in the gut
right yeah cuz she has to get if she if she gets
that close to you she's been getting close to all
of them there you go yeah just get her what do
you do size her head off oh okay cool it's cool
to open up your eyes and be hey it's me Percy
yeah I'm a star of the show here we should take
it with us uh why why would you do that if you
open the eyes they still work Co Dead or Alive
y you never know when something like that might
come in handy maybe towards the end when you're
fighting the ultimate bad guy come on man just
take off your jacket we'll wrap it up until we get
some ice oh why why I got to take off my jacket
because you're the protector oh wow way to push
her around the the black guy this movie has some
racist undertones hey hey guys wait oh fantastic
jewelry piece huh one down two to go oh with what
the Pearl he said he said the Pearl I didn't hear
he said out loud at the Pearl he did I just he
just thought he was jacking her Jewel no I didn't
even yeah I was like wait and then when he pulled
it off I was like oh right we're we're looking for
a pearl I had forgotten what we were doing no D
dude this plot is very very busy yeah I'm back
though going to Nashville Tennessee
where to sing like this uh wake up
dude keep your hoof on the pedal if you're tired
you pull over people let's St yeah good idea oh
my God we're in high school why does that look
so awesome this is a crappy motel and you put
some lights on a tree next to christas motel
it's Tennessee whatever it looks amazing he
he's back in the pool he's healing he's resting
I guarantee you this is a shot from before and
they're like we're just going to use it again
some Motel pool yeah this Motel pool looks nice
all right so let's recap Percy Jackson son of
Poseidon people are hunting him cuz he's got
Bolt and he's going to find three pearls to go
to hades's girlfriend or wife to tell them he
didn't steal any lightning steal anything so he
get his mom back so we can get his mom back from
the Satan guy with the hor and we also got to like
fight Zeus I think in the end lady who turned to
stone she yeah because Zeus he has to convince
Zeus yes yes oh my God and he can heal and he
can heal save your woman I feel like he would have
discovered some of this by accident like with his
mom and at home just like some of this water is
not a distant property I agree but maybe he just
like why do our parents hate each other they both
wanted to be Patron God of Athens the people chose
Athena and um our parents have hated each other
ever since what's your mom like I don't know she's
a real will be don't any Gods see their kids it's
forbidden right after we were born Ze decreed that
the gods couldn't have physical contact with their
mortal Offspring damn I think my mother speaks to
me sometimes in times of trouble I hear her voice
she's crazy just like his dad that's happened to
me yeah that's your father talking him yo because
he's a God and he can these two actors have the
ugliest eyes don't they terrible I hate looking at
him you're on TV surrounding the missing boyy oh
now he's a famous guy too he just gets everything
Mr ugliano talk to me about your son Percy Jackson
no he's not my son he's stepson he did not come
from these loins loins oh he cried to kill me and
he threw his mother on the ground and his [__]
friend that looks cool is it cake or a can shut up
Gabe now I'm a fugitive Gabe's always running his
mouth he's just mad because I busted him up with
my crutches yeah go kill him now he sucks I can't
pee with her watching me uh oh God Stoner oh yeah
you're going to have to come on guys let's hit
the road before Homeland Security shows up come
on guys I really hope they get like government and
Homeland Security involved just to make this plot
even more crazy even crazier yeah now they have
a government official hunting them down I want
to know where Percy sleeps I want to know where
he eats I want to know where he shits in nature
nature complete replica of the paron in Nashville
let's go get the Pearl I love that he's got is two
friends with him to deliver more Exposition and
backstory about Gods it's great that way nobody
gets lost and that way we never have any real
character development with them so Percy Jackson
be like what why huh oh dude it's your mom say
hello it's your mom wonder if she really looks
like that she Longs for her check this out it's
30 ft in the air and this place is filled with
tourists I got an idea P Percy knows everything
we fill this building with water I swim up and get
it oh hey I got my worst toilets you got it
your toilet sh I got my toilet sh just felt like
toilets you guarantee you they didn't use them the
the entire time I wanted to see her reaction being
like what is this invention by Humanity okay so
what are we going to do what's the plan here I got
this you got one who who Hey listen you're going
to kill the janitors chill those are working class
Americans what is it do just put him to sleep
yeah okay and apparently every time someone
makes a sound it doesn't alert the other people
they're not dead they're unconscious now we have
30 minutes come on cool cool I feel like the
second I heard my coworker go ah I would turn
around turn around what happened they didn't
get that pickup shot Greg they forgot Luke how
do you turn on the shoes tell Percy's got to break
into a run okay he's got to build up speed kind of
like a a jet on a Runway okay I totally forgot
he had these shoes yeah me too I was like cool
awesome hold on little grab right there
oh yeah yeah oh no no no no cowards never
mind come on Percy he's got [Music] it Pearl
number two I got it see you later Nashville
there you go man for first job he only had like
a 10-second hiccup Percy Jackson yet again he's
Priceless excellent at everything he do oh man
did they all wake up where are the other people
who were knocked out I think they're possessed
got it we've been expecting you Mr Jackson just
give us the lightning bolt and we'll let you go
I don't have the lightning bolt okay this is bad
what okay this is weird editing man I
love it yo it's cool oh my God it's like
a multi-headed dragon serpent hyra hyra oh
Hydra oh yes they fought it in Hercules and
it's a common mythological creature I should
have put together no now we're never leaving
tum she's won hundreds of batt Game of Thrones you
got a sweet tooth right how this Hydra is just not
snatching them up I have no idea I know I'm like
why aren't they just eating them wow whoa all
right oh my God Percy you're EX excent
at everything you do stop no you can't
K don't their heads grow back yeah
why was she telling him to stop so
feverishly I just killed killed it you
only made it worse yeah it grows back
Percy when you cut off one Hydra head two
more grow back well well well also why aren
you guys running to grab the Pearl like
right now when they were partially dead
I do like the design whenever they go
like more the uh the hellish creatures
yeah I think they do like it does look
like weird fleshy morphing [__] going
on come on Percy get it get it and get
out I need water yeah turn yourself
into water real quick [Music]
oh he can control water now too
he like C powers on that well
now he just washed away the Pearl the
Pearl was right there ohar Place well
I'm just saying the water went over
there was bound to move but I guess
not the door open oh yes coming back a
[Music] smart wow the tourist and pain
customers tomorrow are going to be in for a big
surprise hey it's funny how they cut to her before
they showed us them turning to Stone that's some
great effects that that looks awesome how are
they going to get out of this predicament it's
easy let's give person more Powers single storm
cloud that is expanding over much of Europe and
Asia now he's really going to have to steal the
lightning because this storm is Raging across
the globe the gods are angry we need to get the
last Pearl where's the next location gods are
never angry here in LA are ramping 75 and Sunny I
know that's why Sarah's always in her sweater when
she comes over oh Las Vegas why I've been looking
forward to this look guys remember always put the
eights never the 10 okay we're not here to gamble
I don't even think you're old enough aren't you in
high school I feel like they're like 16 there's
no way they're old enough I mean yeah they're
the definition of adult playing child acting
adult playing [Laughter] children how are they
able to get in here you have you can walk into
a casino and be underage I don't think you can I
feel like I think they checked your ID and stuff
no no not in Vegas you could you could wander in
to any casino you just can't obviously drink or
gamble where would we find a green pearl in this
place I mean maybe on a cocktail waitress or a
showgirl we should start there dude knowing how
tough things are for you you will not find it
at all they're so good it's her signature dish
oh really I don't know there's some type of
like weird illusion thing happening here what
do you mean like there's some manip there's some
manipulation happen here okay you don't get free
[__] in Vegas no you shouldn't eat it what's
wrong with you guys it's really good no what's
wrong with you [Music] guys wow oh no drugs drugs
drugs drugs yeah oh they just took ecstasy this
going to turn into a very different movie so we
go the [Music] hangover this movie is so strange
I love it so much are they high on mushroom having
the greatest time right now this movie is so weird
guys why don't we stay here for a while that
sounds like an amazing idea I mean they have
to be a specific type of food that can affect
the gods let's never leave let's stay here God
my poker face P Poker Face hey man
what the hell is going
on okay that you wouldn't be able to do as
a kid no they're they're in some like weird
illusion yeah okay all right they're falling
for something they're tra here I believe you
not this movie has to have by has dance moves
eat the flow it DS the senses it say that's
his dad don't eat the flow keeps you prisoner
uh hey I think I'm going to go get some a I'll
be right back the flower is what keeps you
prisoner around Focus French Connection huh
good movie never seen it you seen it yet yeah
yeah I think so on DVD what's DVD seriously
whatever I think it's the best movie of the year
wait this year yeah this year 1971 God he's just
been trapped in time there the whole time cool
he wake up are all these people just trapped oh
yeah they're all from different prisoners eating
Lotus oh this is a really fun sequence this is my
favorite sequence of the whole movie what that
easy why see seeing things I really don't want
another lotus flower so please leave me alone is
there a problem Mr Jackson Yo No thank you Percy
Jackson's awake okay whoa what are you doing
with that don't eat that what we have to go
now what are you doing we're having so much fun
no no no no we're not having fun I don't know I
would I would just give into the illusion both
of you need to wake up now look at me look at
me you're in a trance okay we're trapped listen
to me you eat the flowers you're never going to
want to leave okay we'll be stuck here forever
oh that's amazing though but the place looks
great it's like heaven what's wrong with that
nothing I mean yeah this place looks amazing why
leave they want freedom of
will [Music] cool oh good thing he was right
there yeah good thing he was right there table
get cool they get to drive in a Maserati I want
to buy a Maserati now they're coming Zoom go go
this actually feels like a commercial for a
[Music] masera you will never want to leave
now that all makes sense what that was the lair
of the Lotus Eaters they've been luring people
into their traps since ancient times what's
wrong with it though yeah I don't understand
like I don't understand what the negative
consequences other than you get to just have
a great time for the rest of your life for
the rest of your life tomorrow is the 21st
we were in there for 5 days our deadline
is tomorrow at midnight well good thing
you have all the pearls apparently you don't age
there either no you're always hot and dressed up
forever listen Hollywood all right they're
coming here wo to all depraved Souls hello
I'm a depraved Soul how come she doesn't have a
fake disability well we never saw her in the real
world we only saw her at training camp right
yeah but she should like she should have one
she should have like a broken arm or something or
like like her breast weigh her down or something
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah something
that like a teenage boy would write or a 33y
old [Laughter] man oh this a cool set there ain't
no turning back now yeah looks like we're stuck
in here yeah don't worry Percy I have faith
you can k out of any situation you're ever you
always do he's really Unstoppable he really is
who's that creepy guy with a hoodie oh boy who
is that creepy guy let's fun out what happened
to the Medusa head did we forget it no it's in
the backpack or something who are you we need
to see Hades he plays death in Supernatural the
living are not permitted here die and come back
oh watch this yo my friend what up hilarious I
got a few dead people you might recognize
Jackson Grant and who's joining the party
Benjamin Franklin yeah you like that don't you
why would he care about cash there you go yeah
why would we care about that he doesn't need
your money he lives in a tomb drma the drma
coins climb aboard damn per from that Fountain
Percy is smarter thanks for telling me man you
burning money we in a recession shut up
couldn't give I wish the girl the girl
was the one that found them she should have
been like try these right giving our friends
more agency like no let Percy figure this one
out he's known about this [__] for like 36
hours awesome this is that's an awesome
special the underworld of human misery
lost hopes and dreams wishes is that
never came true when they go dark it's
really Embraces something pretty cool
yeah they do that like the dark and the
Mysteries and the Monsters really well in
this film all lives end in suffering and
tragedy wait what's the next part of the plot we
got to get to hades's wife yeah
and then we have to stomp on the
pearls now this looks like a really fun set to be
a part of good job production design team I agree
what that thing what are we going to do this
like frog monsters who who were
those things hell hounds Rosario
dawsona they send the presence of another animal
oh great you smell goat a Seder I haven't had a
Seder yeah dude yeah pan oh hey okay don't ignore
me or what what will you do I'm already in hell I
don't think I've ever seen Rosario Dawson so uh
aggressive volumous heart heart he meant heart
heart heart we have visitors cool gar Steve cougan
welcome you have your father's looks this came out
in like 2010 but every the entire style is like
out of like a '90s like black leather movie yeah
you're right you're Hades yes I didn't expect
you to look like this man would you prefer that
I looked like this cool it's pretty awesome look
look look SP to the m Jagger thing it works for
you this is cheaper you're very brave coming
here I can see the look of disgust in your
eyes but this existence was not of my choosing
looker disgust he's got the same smolder all
the time he's either bewildered or smoldering
my only chance of getting out of this place
defeat my brothers and take control of Olympus
of course um I'll need the bolt and I need my
mother then we have an understanding you give
me the bolt and I'll give you your mother give
me my mom first let me see her let me see
I'm not the Lightning Thief I don't have
the B give me the bolt or say goodbye to
your mother no [Music] uh-oh I feel like
pan is going to do something to help out
finally per wait was the lightning there
the lightning in the thingy oh my God he had
the bolt wait where'd he get the shield from
that guy the blonde guy the blonde guy had
the blonde guy that we all we called it he
was too nice the whole time so of course he
stole the lightning bolt he planted it on
Percy Zeus's Master B oh maybe the blonde guy's
the son of Zeus I don't know how that got there
there not even my shield Luke rigged it
he put the bolt in his shield and used
us that was that is way too
heavy-handed of exposition
somebody somebody could have said something
those deliveries were not I didn't believe
[Applause] it whoa we had a deal all
right you have the bullets let us go
summon the HS dude panie do something
yeah I could It Go as like Supernatural
Terror I feel like this when Chris
Columbus actually had an interest in
making this everything else feels like
do what you did in Harry Potter sort
of go give it back Troublemaker who oh that was
quick why'd you do that he's cruel and abusive
the only thing I look forward to is my allotted
time away from this hell hole she helped out
who would have thought see I think the same
thing my allotted time away from this hell
hole is what I look forward to a war of the
Gods would put an end to that and I'd be alone
with only him take the bolt and your mother she
helped you called it dude I like her look in
this movie only three what there's supposed to
be more each Pearl transports only a single
person the mom make the mom stay Bye Mom no
Junior protector might turn into senior
protector earn your horns yeah he'll do
it I'm staying because I'm the protector just
go it's my duty he's now a senior I I'll take
very good care of him oh yeah I I'd volunteer to
stay yeah obviously I mean it's Rosario [Music]
Dawson
bye oh my goodness no no oh my God is Olympus
just the top of this building man what's this
building maybe what's this iconic building in New
York is that the Chrysler I don't know buildings
I don't know buildings the Chrysler Building I
know the names of build there the Empire State
Building and then there's the Chrysler
Building is Chrysler in New York I don't
know Zeus and beside him preparing for battle
this isn't Olympus this is this is the Empire
State Building Percy the entrance to Olympus
is there you what well you weren't supposed
to make it out alive who would have thought
he was a traitor not us you hid the boat in
my shield why well when you said you were going
to the underworld it hit me that is the perfect
opportunity to get the bolt to Hades why would
you do that to bring Olympus crumbling down
well it's too late cuz I'm returning the bolt to
Zeus right now why would you do that not before
[Music]
midnight wow these wire effects are [Music]
phenomenal over 100 Battles let's go why do
you want to war the gods they've been Empower
for too long I say it's time for our generation
to take over a world of new Heroes you're
no hero [Music] no you missed oh you missed
again it's hard to hit them when they're
so far away is it is that you're a yeah
I mean he's obviously those that's three three
strikes you're at you you you should just lose
the the bolt immediately now that rubble's
probably affecting all those citizens down
below whoa that's pretty cool you got this
Percy now the guy's not afraid of heights at all
oh my God Percy's found his
equal [Music] awesome he's flying he can fly they
can fly they got the they got the the feet thingy
the wings oh right hey why can he fly cuz they
both have it oh right he had tons of you guys
sorry he just can fly so straight all of the
sudden before he was like he's
Percy Jackson he's learned I get
it no no summon water or something
you're surrounded by water
everywhere you really think
that would have been a lot worse
hey you put that down maybe they were wrong
maybe you're no son of posidon the actor's
real accent um started coming through
they here summon water show you where
the son of Poseidon cool oh there
was a just happened to be a water
tank hey there's no such thing
as coincidence in this universe
now would be a good chance to strike him
with some lightning okay yep a little late
okay rise
Percy dude not not a not a single drip of
water on Percy Jackson he managed to stay
completely dry I am so hungry I you're
right you Tera asked me before filming
if I should grab some water I should
have done it you should have done it
sorry I then effed up yeah I think
I am the son of [Music] sidon that
line he is just he says I think he
is just too perfect at everything
man he's like everything I
want to be it feels like a
teenage boy imagined himself as Percy
Jackson and got everything he wanted
yeah so much
gold where he's going to go see Zeus now
I guess so to give him back the lightning
bolt I said we don't talk about this movie
when it's done we immediately start the
sequel kill
me hey you're a wizard Harry it is almost
midnight this was predestined you wanted
this battle you have only yourself to blame
let irrational war is not the answer answer
great accent time has run out wait sequel
oh is not the answer Papa [Music] wow oh
oh they're massive my name is Percy Jackson
and I think you might be looking for this I
have your lightning boat I wonder if they
hear their voices like hi my name is Percy
Jackson give me the bolt Lightning
Thief
cool you're wise to betray your father I didn't
steal it and I have no connection to Poseidon
and who did Luke son of Hermes you know Luke
he was angry at you all of you he wanted you
to destroy yourselves cuz you ain't been around
hi Mom I am so proud of you I have a good friend
he's a Sader named Grover he's my protector and
the only reason why we escape the underworld is
because he stayed behind and now you expect
me to bring him back very well yeah he went
through hell to get you a goddamn lightning
bolt I'm not expecting you to forgive me but I
want you to know that I'm grateful I didn't do
it for you I did it to save Mom see you later
dad whoa we don't have much time oh he's small
now how old was I when you left 7 months look I
didn't need you there all the time I would
have liked to have seen you just once why
didn't you ever come back you know yeah like
through the sink or through the bathtub or
like I'm showering just show up yeah when I
was with you and your mother I became less
concerned with my responsibilities what are
your responsibilities I was becoming human oh
no what are your responsibilities that's why he
passed the law preventing Gods from ever having
contact with this children that was because
of you like when the earthquake hits and then
the wave comes but he gets in and he's like I
know I'm not the father you always wanted but
if you ever need me I'll be there for you in the
waves in your thoughts and in your dreams that's
sweet what if he's dreaming about the daughter
of Athena that's he shows not the wet ones just
to be like Gregory you're doing good son you
pleasure son oh God just promised me that I
don't have to see that loser Gabe ever again
I kicked him out yeah he's gone he's out of
our lives forever can you clear my name on the
news too so I don't seem like a drug dealing
kidnapper Bye
Mom hey dude get some new clothes so the
Conquering Hero returns Triumph Grover hey
he doesn't walk we weird he could be wearing
jeans I mean I agree but it's a little this
looks like got a huge ad scoliosis thing here a
new clone smell good he's a a horn oh I see I've
seen him the whole time look at that thing got a
little horns in your head now see him Protector
first class baby congratulations you're so cool
Percy Jackson left the camp disobeyed my orders
you deliberately disobeyed me but you did good kid
oh um which is why you're my favorite student you
do nothing wrong Percy you can receive all the
training in the world but ultimately you have to
follow your instincts then you've also required
no training to do good I think I'd like to give
it a shot in more ways than one welcome [Music]
home their eyes UNC comfortable grab who who wait
first Dr of battle strategy don't ever let your
opponent distract you sexuality always distracting
me roll credit doesn't look choreographed at
all feels very spontaneous yeah no they're
just they're looping around with
sword they're just doing a thing
cuz they knew they were going to
do a drone shot and they're like
nobody really pay attention to what we're
doing over here Canada and it's [Music]
over if I could stand without
leaving the frame I would screw
it I'm not doing it I'm not doing it weird go
I'm not doing it yeah that you need you need the
sticks for okay you can't just whip on jeans
and people not go like what's going on there
okay let's look up if there's a post credit scene
before um uh oh that's frozen that happens before
we stick around for all this does Percy Jackson
and the Olympians the Lightning Thief have open
the door open up answered oh my God he's like
related Delux yes this guy so here's your junk
you can let yourself out how am I supposed to
move all this stuff by myself deal with it yeah
girl slam that door in his face she has agency
she's like panie I need a beer get it yourself do
not oh yay he's is going to die now it's like by
lightning nice I wanted him to Die
the whole time I love that it [Music]
happened I love that he died and he was
turned to stone Percy Jackson killed
him oh there I do wish they would have given
Athena's daughter hold on hey reject Nation you
know running real rejects is an incredible journey
something I am truly grateful for but I got to be
real with you for one second here managing the
business side especially taxes to put it lightly
is incredibly overwhelming it's like navigating
a maze without a map and that's where our sponsor
rocket money comes in a sponsor when approached
I was so excited to work with because I kid you
not just last month I started using rocket money
cuz I needed to sort out this financial puzzle
and honestly it's been quite eye opening not just
for taxes but boy oh boy that whole cliche of this
app is true I discovered apps and subscriptions
I have been paying for that I had not used in
ages it is like finding out you've been leaving
lights on in a room that you never use so yes
rocket money isn't just another app it's like a
freaking Financial Guardian Angel it finds and
cancels this forgotten subscriptions monitors
your spending and even battles to lower your
bills thank God it's as if they're personally
invested in saving your hard-earned money like
I try I really try to be on top of my expenses
but rocket money they show me blind spots with a
simple tab I can cancel unnecessary subscriptions
they even handle the hassle of negotiating with
customer services a relief my goodness to put it
into perspective rocket money has helped over 5
million users save an average of $720 a year
that's more than just numbers it's a piece of
mind so I invite you my fellow Rejects and taking
control of your finances so go ahead visit rocket
money.com rejects once again that's rocket
money.com rejects let's save together rocket
money.com rejects I really do stand by this app
thank you for partnering with us so as many of you
guys know most of my days are a couple of hours of
filming and then most of the time it's dedicated
to like editing and a bunch of other computer
work often accumulating to like 10 to 12 hours
a day and on top of that comfort food is like
my life's biggest Vice but as many of you also
know working out and getting healthier has been a
massive component for me this year in particular
so in this Whirlwind I have found myself a perfect
Ally for quick healthy meals America's number one
meal kit a meal kit that I have subscribed to
prior to ever agreeing and working with them
so yes this is a genuine testimony and that
is of course for hello fresh and hellofresh
is in just about ease about bringing health
and flavor to your doorstep in this holiday
season forget about the stress of planning meals
for your healthc conscious friends friends like
me who will breathe down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's unhealthy so
with hello fresh I'm looking forward to hosting
holiday dinners that are not only delicious but
also cater to Healthy Lifestyles best part
the variety it is incredible I'm pescatarian
so they have these delicious meals just like
dejon onion crunch Simon over lemon broccoli
spaghetti and from my more plant-based days the
vegan Maple carrot power bowls they aren't just
meals they're culinary Adventures I learned
the word culinary during a long day the last
thing I want to do is spend a while cooking and
that's where hellofresh is 15minute meals are a
lifesaver they're quick nutritious and Oho tasty
perfect for my non-stop lifestyle so why not join
me in making this holiday season both health
conscious and delicious with hellofresh with
over 45 recipes and seasonal add-ons to choose
from every week there's always something new to
try and here's something to cheer about go to
hellofresh.com reject free and use code reject
free for free breakfast for life is that accurate
that sounds way too good to be true there's no
way that can be true go to hellofresh.com reject
free and use code rejects free for free breakfast
for Life One breakfast item per box as long as
your subscription is active tag your hellofresh
trations with # hellofresh piic and at hellofresh
and let's cook up some fun and healthiness reject
Nation remember it's America's number one meal kit
I do wish they would have given Athena's daughter
more stuff to do give the girl stuff cuz the goat
guy he got some stuff he got to like protect him
and whatnot but really thought she was going
to get more of a role in saving him cuz I think
that have just been cool she did when she was up
in the Chrysler Building whatever like slightly
EMP State Building the Empire State Building you
got Chrysler in my head because you said it five
times it's not my fault it's his now listen I'm
going I'm going to just throw I'm going to throw
categories your way go ahead I'm going help
you out here action what do you think of the
action I like the the action I did I I when you
say action I'm like I have to go through all of
like the action stuff uh and we already discussed
how when it gets like dark and Moody and there's
like the Satan figures which is mainly when the
action happens that uh that it's awesome that it
looks cool I like it it's cool right I'm into
it I like when that stuff happens but what I
what I didn't like I honestly I think that it all
looked really it looked great and I thought all
the action is good and I like the special effects
he didn't like the Medusa thing I was like I think
those look real and weird I was I was down with it
I mean from up close not so much but from when she
was further away I was like oh gross um sure yeah
okay I'll give you that okay uh but the yeah the
exposition did drive me crazy and after a while
it was weird there's a couple parts in this where
these are good actors that they'll say a line
and I'm like yeah no one said hold on I don't
believe that let's go back let's settle you're you
say this line and let's hopefully we believe you
and there's a few parts where I that digs under
my skin I hate it I do not like it when I don't
believe an actor for the rest of the time I did
believe him yeah yeah I'll meet you on all those
points I'll meet you on all those points action
was fine not the problem is is that there's no
real like Stakes so there's no real intensity
it's more like oh this is like fun action but
the movie has such a fast pace that you're like
ah screw it whatever I'm on board I'll watch it
it's it's action yeah and yeah the visual effects
were real up and down for me sometimes they look
great and other other times it looked really like
fake like I thought the dragon looked great the
Satan guy when he was like fire that looked cool
and also this is an older movie so I I I do have
that understanding that it's an older film so
it's not going to look as up to par the goat and
the centaurs looked good uh some of that Pier BR
and stuff though you didn't think sometimes weird
when he walked that one time when he was walking
where I was like he's trying to sell it too much
or they told him that I don't know I didn't know
what they were doing um yeah I think the visual
effects can be a little bit wonky but most of
the time it looked actually all right and and
then she talked about that uh what you think
of p and yeah to your point about the acting
um yeah I mean usually if every cuz I've seen
I've seen most of these people in other movies
where they do great job yeah at everyone here no
one's no one's great in this movie all right like
no one's great here um the most believable one
is the abusive husband Joe pantell he's the most
believable one great and Zeus did a great job but
he's only in two seconds of this movie yeah the
way you would expect them to use Zeus where as you
build them up in your franchise like everyone is
reasonably Charming I suppose um and it it usually
comes down to like overall direction I'm I'm under
the impression here's the impression I'm under
that Chris Columbus yeah let's let's confirm
like cuz what year is this is he in between Harry
Potter movies at this point after like a couple
Harry Potters that that it's like h fine I'll do
it you know that's kind of the impression that
I have of there's like not okay 2001 uh okay I
think he did Chamber of Secrets which was the
last one he did if I'm not mistaken yes he did
Chamber of Secrets okay and then he eventually
comes back and does like this fantasy movie which
has ear it's not exactly Harry Potter but there's
some similarities you could totally draw action
sequences the way the camera who lives amongst
the normal life an abusive household like there's
a lot of a lot of similarities um but I'm under
the impression that they were like yeah we liked
what you do with Harry Potter and he didn't really
he he did it for the paycheck I I got a real like
hey let's get the guy did Harry Potter to do his
thing and he there's like a not a real passion
behind the camera for this and I get the sense
of that and I I there because it's a bit messy
it's it's truncated and it's kind of moving out
of whiplash pace and um yeah there's a lot of like
flat dialogue but I I I'd be so lying to you guys
if I said that I I did not have fun I so had fun
watching this and I know book readers hate this
movie so I'm not trying to appease anyone here he
doesn't read I don't read I'm I'm dyslexic which
is apparently a gift yeah he can read great ADHD
is a and you know there is an argument to made
for that ADHD is a blessing and a curse so I know
all about it yeah I've been diagnosed with it and
um and other things as well and and I could say
that oh it's I could totally see how it's actually
helped get me places in life this movie has a
weird commentary about it I don't quite get what
they're saying it's I don't either or like maybe
ADH or this dyslexia and then you're like oh are
you just trying to say it is what I just said a
blessing and a curse well a lot of things don't
have time to breathe or like simmer in it get it
point across right no we're just we're on to the
next thing it's just move move move move with a
bunch of like really good actors in here yeah um
oh it's only two writers I thought it'd be like
way more writers only two um I like Logan lurman
he's really he's Charming oh yeah I I love him I
mean I love him from Love and monster so much I
love that movie um and that's mainly why what I
know from but uh in this yeah that there're both
I think all three of them I mean especially her
um she's in another thing they're all good actors
it's just there are certain points in this where
they're two times with each actor they've set a
line and I've gone did nobody stop to think we're
not going to use that take that they need to say
it like we believe it it was weird I was like did
we maybe they ran out of time they're like you get
one take and then it sucked I don't know um but as
a whole they didn't suck and I did have fun it's
good actors in here just those things really can
eat me alive yeah yeah you know like I I like like
I've read the some of the Harry Potter books and
then watching the movies I was like oh these are
actually these are pretty good adaptations from
from book to film they're pretty good adaptations
and I have no idea what the book is like I didn't
even know the story at all right like does he win
in the book too every time or does he go through
some more trials and tribulation there's like no
Stakes when it comes to Percy Jackson but you you
get the impression watching this that they went
how do we take this book and condense it into
the save the cat movie structure that's exactly
you could tell you could feel the Hollywood uh
mechanics behind it yeah without even reading a
book I'm like yeah I can completely see how they
have tried taking [__] and putting it into like
their basic Hollywood outline this is like akin
to when people say a movie feels like algorithm
made and this feels algorithm made of like I bet
there's a much stronger Source material out there
because holy [__] the way the script moves
this is like this it is it is totally all over
the place there is no real emotional depth that
has no time to let situations breathe to Warren
Stakes it is one of those movies where everything
is constantly being um washed over by H whatever
Exposition and I'm having fun yeah that's that's
that's the film but I just get so mad at that it
wasn't just like multiple things of I mean yes
it wasn't just a few things of exposition it was
a lot almost every time they were met with a new
circumstance they had to say it out loud why they
were there or remind us what they were doing oh
yeah they like idiots I'm like yeah but can't we
give those characters a different line that says
something about them and their like moral code as
to why they're there but we didn't do that and
so yeah there were no Stakes as big Stakes but
there also weren't really any individual Stakes
either except for like we all got Daddy problems
and hi Mom hi Dad once we got there and yeah
he got his horns at the end but like there's
information there's yeah there's info there's
just not we didn't play with it enough and we
didn't give the characters any dialogue to EXP
explore that information that was like we have
daddy issues and it was like instead of exposition
we could have pulled away to have a conversation
of like well this is bugging me you probably
have the same problem here's how we Bond and
now we're going to be able to fight this thing
better because we bonded or whatever but that
didn't happen that's all right that's all right
you know I my I'm here to direct the next one if
you want that's all right that's all right I'll
give some notes book readers who have seen the
I haven't even seen the TR for the Disney Plus
show but apparently like it the the author of I
I heard the author of this movie like walked out
of the theater or like cried at how terrible it
was something like that at this movie yeah just
of how like un Unfaithful how they Dam terrible
cuz to me I'm like no this feels like another run
ofe Mill you know youth fantasy movie where the
kids are played by adults and and there's like
really wooden direction and you slap in a a cat
cast full an ensemble full of famous actors who
don't really have there's like no reason to get
famous like you don't need Rosario Dawson you
don't need Uma Thurman no they barely bring
anything to the role because there's nothing
really in the script them chew you just you
do it for marketing purposes it's one of those
things yeah you know and uh so to me it's like
another one of run middle of a ya novel brought
to life um but there is like a Whimsy and just a
fast-paced about this that allows it to be a bit
of a Breeze despite how predictable it is like
it's one of those things where I should hate this
movie but I don't no and I'm not trying to satisfy
anyone we don't care we knew we knew people didn't
like pitch we knew people love pitch black we got
so much crap and we're like we don't like this
movie and this movie is one of those where I'm
like I feel like I shouldn't like it and I don't
know if I do but I had fun I had fun too like I'm
not going to watch it again if someone was like
going while I'd be like no I don't need to do
that um but in this format of reactions yes it's
it makes for an enjoyable like filming a reaction
yeah yeah I agree a good time yeah that's where
we're at we're at good times right we we had fun
we like it we love you uh you got last words
before I close this puppy out uh no I think we
talked about uh oh my gosh apple and Spotify if
you're listening is too late to addit it in it's
too late too dang it but I'm also you know what
I am too I'm a sucker for like myth whenever you
throwing like weird mythological [__] I'm I'm
a sucker for you love it yeah even though I don't
know it like I don't actually know it whenever
I see ear marks of it or anything like oh Medusa
or whatever it it feels like the like like a
Hollywood studio Cinematic Universe thing that
I'm just like yeah it's cheesy but whatever I'm
having fun it's cool cuz we don't see it enough
yeah it's just God thing we don't get that a lot
yeah yeah just have it all thrown in there is is
fun cuz it's got this uh it's 2000s but it's it's
got this like weird Middle Ground of '90s and 2000
you know that '90s leather thing that happen thing
with Uma and with Steve right that they're in full
leather or like then the dudes show up and they're
like I'm Zeus in the modern world like you guys
seem like you're out of a 90s movie yeah um that
that that look but from like Matrix to Charlie's
Angels era you know where they all have that look
and that's what they have here is that look they
got a look anyway I'm done I'm done they got a
look he's done leave a like leave a comment tell
us how cool we are don't forget to subscribe um
you guys know the deal if you're not on patreon
get on it I don't know what else I say at the end
he's throwing coasters around this is a terrible
environment save me from it okay we love you so
much we'll see you on the next one all right John
pick a name all right here we go here we go let's
do adilia Chamberlain Adelia Chamberlain do you
know what you're getting for Christmas it's
good this year you are going to get a pencil
oh you could do a lot with that a pencil that is
not sharpened so endless potenti you're going to
have a little Adventure where you're going to see
the magic of what it's like to sharpen a pencil
because let's face it no one does it anymore man
they don't they don't need to they're obsolete
now it's either a pen you can't find or a keyboard
of sorts or that goes on a screen that you can't
find exactly now you're going to R you're going
to use it to ReDiscover the child within you who
sharpens pencils anymore and it won't be an
electric sharper which are which are really
the fun ones when you just it comes out a sharp
or the cranky one you know that's that's the one
you're going to get you're going to get the cranky
one yeah and good luck telling if it's going to be
one of the ones that has that real satisfying nice
grinder or if it's one of the messed up ones but
you only get one pencil and and you know sometimes
in those cranky ones they don't turn out so great
sometimes you got to go for a while and they Gore
up your tip and they really mess it up so if if
you botch that one pencil that's on you man sorry
that's on you it's on all of us imagine if you if
you sharpen the perfect pencil and what do you do
with that pencil you take it to a piece of paper
again a piece of Parliament that no one really
has anymore but if you're able to take it to that
paper and you start writing your novel using that
creative brain of yours scribble away and then
what happens you'll have to resharpen that pencil
that sweet sweet pencil because let's face it the
more you use it the smaller it's going to get
and then you're going to have to get more paper
and then before you know it maybe about two hours
in you're going to go this would have been more
efficient if I just typed this I see why people
are moving ahead with technology after all I've
given to Greg and John at the patreon page yeah
they give me a pencil what is this some kind of
insult yeah yeah you need be put in your place
that's again yeah but you know congratulations
yeah the number two pencil hey it's a classic
though all right it is John was obsessed with
mechanical pencils in school I was I thought
they were the bee's knees and now look at me
now I love a good wood pencil I know yeah we're
always using pencils always around the office
I'm like don't bring me any ink don't bring
me that computer give signing checkbooks and
pencils yeah yeah don't worry man I'll fix I'll
fix any smudges you might happen to make on that
you know it's my honor but um in all seriousness
uh I hope you enjoy that pencil it's a good one
there's so much you can do feed all your creative
endeavors and I'll serious uh I hope that I know
Christmas time gathered with the family where
there's uh political views flying left and right A
lot it can be a lot to discern the two and having
to mediate and just be content with the immediate
situation I understand how tough that can be where
you got to [__] your way through its family just
[__] just smile I get it i' I'm there all the
time I hope they're watching so they know what I
deal with but that's why a pencil comes in handy
cuz you can take yourself away their ass that's
right you can kill every one of them and people
are going to be impressed no matter what like
they're not going to investigate you cuz people
are going to be like you did that with a pencil
how bad teach me that is intense yeah for YouTube
disclaimer we are joking we are not actually
encouraging the harm of others HT behaviors
sharpen pencil even if it would be a a good even
though it would be pretty interesting pretty fun
to try out you know movies like something about
that like so like if you're I've hurt myself on
a pencil before you know weird you're like it's
a pencil yeah it's such an innocuous item and yet
you could do such damage yeah and they Splinter
when they break all kinds of stuff or like uh or
have you ever hurt yourself on a quill it's almost
impossible but it can be done it can be done
especially if you get one of those fancy metal
tippet ones pointy as hell which is the best
writing tool to do some damage with chat gbt
bab the the machine is mightier than the pen
is mightier than the sword love you Adelia
Merry Christmas I hope Santa comes down that
shelf exhausted going why didn't you clear the
fireplace and then reaches into that back pulls
out of bed and then it burns all this H to give
you this for this I check my list enough time
to the pencil at your face I hope you're happy
to hell with you I'm walking out the door I
wasted 70 seconds on this house it's a kid
waiting for something I don't know I could have
just thrown the pencil down here going to just
dropped this and hoped you find it gone off and
continue delivering ps5s Merry [Music] Christmas